Judy the trigger here comes Rodney hood  against women's need for the best  defender force the switch put against  Turner's  [Applause]  no Larry Nance Jr the Cavalier hero  Danny - Danny laughs believe me Fred it  was deserving because the man has played  a great great game he's done he's done  pretty much everything tonight for the  Cavaliers and for him to get an  opportunity that is apropos for the  catalyst is deserving a great night by  Nance and a great finish  he did it in Tristan Thompson style  Jesse way the persistence of following  up and Tristan is out there  congratulating they'll look to make sure  to put the stamp on it but Larry Nance  Jr with at all right hand to knock it in  and the Cavaliers with a gutsy win their  best of the season against the Pacers  ending their seven-game win streak doing  a great job see that move